i'm crying you're crying yeah gang come
right here
come right here goes katie come right
here here katie
all right grip on this stand right here
stand right here
i literally saw ourselves all right now
you guys grab that box of tissues
because it's about to get
real freaking emotional in here us too
we probably don't have any emotion but
when you get us
you really get it yeah well on sunday's
episode of american idol aspiring singer
courtney timmons
really got him i literally saw her
sidewalk right now here's what went down
ryan seacrest met
court a 22 year old security guard from
georgia
on the street where she was waiting
hoping she might get a chance
to sing for the judges ryan pointed out
that auditions had already started and
producers
just might not be down with her jumping
in so late in the game
but he was willing to bring her into the
studio himself
the solution to that problem is me just
taking you up there and seeing if they
let you go
okay i can't promise you because i
haven't asked them but at least if we
get up there
they have to say no to your face which
is probably harder now mind you
ryan still hadn't heard her sing bold
move ryan
bold move i grabbed her and brought up
the elevator
this is the stuff that tv gold is made
of people can't you feel
the feel goods brewing oh bring it on
no one has heard her we don't have any
idea what she sounds like are you
kidding me this is the
this is the first you know where this is
going right
[Music]
yeah she was freaking awesome
i literally have chills over my whole
body
[Music]
like i said people tv gold
hold on before the show started i saw
her
sitting outside on the sidewalk i
thought you were just kind of a fan of
the show
you can sing no no no you can sing
it's the difference between singing and
singing you are a bird girl
and the judges they freaking loved it
you're one of the best singers we've
seen today
really oh my gosh you're probably the
best singer we've seen today absolutely
correct
courtney timmons yes security guard from
georgia
this is really magical this is a magical
moment
we're gonna send you to hollywood and
cue the waterworks would you do me a
favor ryan i would
would you do me a favor right now you go
over there where she is
yes sir sorry i'm like a parent i'm
crying you're crying
yeah gang come right here come right
here goes katie
come right here here katie all right
grip on this
stand right here stand right here i
literally saw her sidewalk all right now
well us too we probably don't have any
emotion but when you get us you really
get it
hold on courtney you know what you are
what american idol is
[Music]
we didn't fill the deal for you you
ready oh my gosh you're one
two three you're going to holly
[Music]
it's just so good anyway ryan hit up
social media after the emotional moment
tweeting quote
i'm crying katy perry is crying america
is crying
we're all crying courtney was the
american idol curveball we didn't know
we needed
so proud of her e.t was actually with
ryan
katie luke bryan and lionel richie at
those auditions in savannah georgia back
in october
and they teased the tear-filled moment
there's this
young lady who's literally sitting on
the sidewalk just waiting for someone to
say hi to her
she wants to be around the action she
never really formally
auditioned and someone's heard her
producers yeah someone's heard her kind
of singing
in the background i was like excuse me
do you sing and
um she said yes and she just came up
here and ryan
picked her out didn't even know what
she's saying like right she's a security
guard
at a company not far from here at a
paper mill uh-huh and she came in she
got two kids
and she was gonna wait all day until you
guys walked out to try and sing
at your base right yeah right right
right and patiently waiting and she came
in and what'd you think
well well we were let me tell you what i
thought you were crying and i said
that i have never seen then katie's
crying
and i were actually lost you guys
don't really get creepy
that's what this american idol is about
it's about finding that special moment
making someone's dream come true
it is like truly the definition of the
american dream
which sometimes we feel is a little
shaky in what the time we're living in
now like what do we have to believe in
and i think we can believe in in humans
again and
get a mother of two to get in her car
yes
be determined say she's not going to
hear the word no
and and she yeah she can and she's going
to hollywood
just when i thought i was over american
idol they got me again
hook line and sinker of course you can
count on e.t to bring you all the latest
from this season so make sure to keep it
locked
right here until next time i'm hallie
stevens and i'll see you soon
a bigger piece of tissue oh yeah that
was a little dinky one
i literally have chills over my whole
body
was it stupid